[Applaudissements]
j'en sais quelque chose
jean-michel le plus dur pour vous ça va
être de rester concentré ouais c'est ça
je recommande quoi qu'il arrive de ne
pas consommer sur le plateau des gens
nous regardent
attention tout ce qu'ils ont dans c'est
ce que la régie peut me le dire a très
bien
c'est allé c'était quoi je suis appuyé
sur le bouton et je descends lac à
fermont amoros way est maintenant sur un
cheech en diable et jean michel mr et
capucine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mieux
tu
[Musique]
ici
quel dommage qu'elle de base de capucine
n'ai pas été à la hauteur parce que jean
michel six ouais non matin c'était de la
boucherie ont cessé on est à un autre
niveau là c'est l'uniforme la nôtre jeux
truqués et ses plaies après partie je
vais être honnête avec vous on vous
dansiez pas la même dans son but
d'éviter soir lé coach vous nominer avec
moi en données volées
c'est ici que ça va se passer on sera là
on dira que demain on sera là on dirait
que la prémar et dès que le générique se
terminera sas rapid l'heure pour le
match de foot ne vous inquiétez pas
c'est sûr et il ya limités à ceux ci sur
ces huit que je vous conseille qui est
un super film c'est parti pour le compte
à rebours bas mesdames et messieurs
c'était nos invités
[Applaudissements]
dur
qui est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et 6 mai
ma
m
qui
[Musique]